yves buisson merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on le disait
un rebond des cas de contamination en
france que vous êtes inquiet inquiet non
mais très attentif à l'évolution de
cette épidémie qui déjoue toutes les
prévisions
on pouvait espérer que le comique 19
s'arrêterait avec le début de l'été avec
les chaleurs il n'en a rien été puisque
contrairement à ce que l'on peut
observer avec les infections grippales
ou avec d'autres corps aux navires aux
est bien le cas que 8,19 à continuer de
se manifester pendant les mois de
juillet le mois d'août et même on
assiste à une certaine recrudescence
donc c'est intéressant il faut en tenir
compte
il faut pas non plus tirer une sonnette
de la semaine des larmes de façon
excessive puisque c'est une suite
logique de cette épidémie de ce virus
qui est très très content a lieu dans
une population qui est totalement ou en
grande majorité réceptif parce qu'elle
n'a pas d'immunité collective donc les
mesures qui doivent être prises sont les
mesures que l'on a largement répété et
il faut s'y tenir si on veut éviter
effectivement que cette recrudescence
deviennent insupportables et conduisent
à des mesures de confinement
alors là aux seins des contaminations se
confirme donc on le disait mais toujours
sans impact hospitalier pour le moment
en tout cas
à dix sept personnes deux mois
hospitalisé depuis mardi comment est ce
que vous le comprenez d'abord on sait
qu'il ya toujours un décalage de deux
trois voire quatre semaines entre la
déclaration de nouveaux cas de
contamination et l'impact sur les appels
aux urgences les hospitalisations les
entrées en réanimation et par la suite
malheureusement les décès donc ce n'est
pas parce qu'on n'a pas d'impact
actuellement sur ces chiffres de 2
spitter lisation réanimation et sur le
taux de l'essai qu'il faut se dire que
finalement rien n'est grave
non il ya de plus en plus de nouveaux
cas et ceci doit être pris en
considération
mais si la plupart de ces nouveaux cas
c'est sûr viennent plutôt dans des
tranches d'âge plus jeune donc moins à
risque de faire des formes graves
toutefois il faut être extrêmement
attentif parce que nous sommes dans une
période de grande mobilisation de la
population en raison des vacances est
donc grande circulation du virus
donc il faut être extrêmement prudent et
attentif
même si encore une fois il n'y a pas
lieu tout de suite de tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé
il faut être vigilant alors le
controversé professeur didier raoult le
teint s'est exprimé il ya quelques jours
sur une chaîne d'information lui dit
constater un virus moins virulent que
celui qu'on avait pu observer au début
de l'épidémie est ce que vous rejoignez
ce constat je n'ai aucun élément pour
confirmer cette assertion c'est possible
mais je ne sais pas sur quoi s'appuient
ces propos ceux ci c'est sur le fait que
par rapport au nombre de nouvelles
contaminations il y a moins de forme
grave on te parle déduire
systématiquement que c'est que le virus
est devenu moins agressif et moins et
moins virulent il faut voir que on
dépiste beaucoup plus on dépiste
beaucoup plus de personnes qui n'ont qui
ne présentent aucun symptôme donc dans
les nouveaux cas déclarés il y a près de
la moitié des cas qui sont aussi ou
asymptomatiques
donc c'est parce qu'on des fonds on
pendait on dépiste plus qu'on trouve
plus néanmoins là le nombre de nouveaux
cas augmentent plus vite que le nombre
de dépistages
ce qui veut dire quand même que on est
dans une phase de recrudescence
mais la recrudescence observe plutôt que
dans des tranches d'âge plus jeune donc
moins un risque de formes de faire des
formes graves et je pense que c'est
plutôt cette raison qui explique le fait
qu' à moins de deux spécialisations et
moins de décès constatés actuellement
depuis cette reprise de l'épidémie qui
remonte déjà au mois de juillet alors
l'organisation mondiale de la santé elle
a déclaré qu'un nouveau confinement
strict comme on l'a connu ne serait pas
nécessaire en europe
car les états ont pris les mesures
suffisantes qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je suis assez de cet avis je pense que
nous sommes tout à fait dans une
situation différente de celle que nous
étions au moins de mars et d'avril
puisque maintenant nous avons les moyens
de dépistage nous savons réagir nous
savons faire le traçage autour des cas
et prendre des mesures très rapidement
d'isolement des han han 14/n des
patients contaminés
donc toutes ces mesures nous avons
appris à l'est à les maîtriser et à les
mettre en oeuvre ce que nous ne savions
pas faire il ya quatre mois donc on est
maintenant prêt et on avait bien sûr des
capacités de diagnostic de dépistage qui
sont infiniment supérieure à celle que
nous avions au départ où nous étions en
face de pénurie faut bien reconnaître
par ailleurs il y a et il faut insister
là dessus
des mesures qui restent fondamentales
qui sont les mesures qui visent à
empêcher la propagation du virus de
personne à personne
notamment le port du masque il faut
insister sur ce port du masque que c'est
qu'on en parle tout le temps on en
revient toujours à cette histoire de
port de masques mais pour l'instant on
n'a rien trouvé de mieux pour empêcher
la transmission d'une personne porteuse
du virus à une personne qui n'a pas le
virus et bien c'est le port du masque
est la meilleure méthode bien entendu il
faut y associer les mesures barrières et
de lavage des mains mais le port du
masque doit rester la mesure
fondamentale et qu'il faut maintenir
coûte que coûte dans non seulement dans
les espaces clos mais également dans
tout l'espace public en milieu urbain
merci beaucoup et 800 d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
épidémiologistes et président du groupe
commis de 19 de la can à l'hymne
national de médecine